[Música]
desde niña he sentido una enorme empatía
por los animales en mis más atesorados
recuerdos de la niñez están mis padres
tratando de ayudar a un perro o gato en
situación vulnerable y luego esos mismos
animales siendo parte importante de mi
vida no olvidó que detuvimos el auto
para ayudar un perro y rescatarlo de un
basurero o aquel minino que buscado
hogar y nosotros pudimos dárselo así
puedo nombrar cada historia de cada
animal que se ha presentado en mi vida y
que guardo en mi corazón la importancia
de esto fue joven gran medida lo que hoy
soy como persona y los fuertes cimientos
que sostiene mi proyecto la seguridad de
ver a mis guías me refiero a mis padres
actuando en pro de mejorar de alguna
forma la situación de estos seres ha
sido la raíz de este sueño que es dejar
un mensaje fuerte y claro en la sociedad
sobre la tendencia responsable ya su vez
poder ayudar a cientos de animales con
los que nos hemos cruzado en el camino
que por alguna razón generaron que hoy
este sueño se haya formalizado pues es
bien sabido que la esencia de lo mágico
está en el actuar no en el decir
el deseo de ayudar y mejorar la vida de
estos seres vivos en estado vulnerable
se convirtió en una inquietud muy
latente en todos mis días y se
transformó en claras acciones durante
mis años de adolescente y creció
conforme llegue a la edad adulta sin
embargo fue hasta la universidad que esa
voz inquieta se hizo más presente fue en
esa etapa cuando le puse más atención y
ahora sé que ese impulso que permití
manifestarse venía de acciones natas del
corazón he reafirmado que esas acciones
son las que nunca necesitan meditarse
tanto
según datos oficiales proyectados por el
inegi respecto a la situación de
abandono maltrato y crueldad hacia los
animales
méxico ocupa el tercer lugar entre todos
los países de latinoamérica
ello pone en evidencia cuáles son las
maneras de actuar que predominan en el
país en lo referente a las formas en las
que tratamos a otros seres vivos sólo el
30 por ciento de los animales que se
categorizan como domésticos
predominantemente perros y gatos tienen
una casa y un dueño para ser más
precisos únicamente 19.5 millones de
estos animales tienen esa oportunidad y
aunque esos números van en aumento es
doloroso saber que no todos tienen
condiciones de vida dignas
tales datos son una de las razones por
las que el sueño de concretar acciones
en beneficio del bienestar animal y la
tenencia responsable tomaron una gran
fuerza en mí hace más de 12 años en el
año 2010 cuando recién había egresado la
licenciatura y estudiaba la maestría
decidí poner todos mis conocimientos en
crear una campaña social que resaltará
la problemática del abandono y el
maltrato animal
estas acciones se formalizarían siendo
vocera por más de un año en la primera
asociación civil fundada de mi ciudad
para más tarde tener la creación de una
asociación propia que tocar acciones de
rescate concientización y adopción como
efecto inmediato comenzar con un espacio
improvisado en ese entonces que nos
permitirá rehabilitar física y
emocionalmente a cada animal que llegaba
con nosotros hoy en día sigo trabajando
en aquel sueño que ya se ha convertido
en toda una realidad un proyecto que se
creó en primer lugar buscando dejar un
mensaje en la sociedad de forma
inmediata por y para nuestros animales y
como segundo lugar contar con un espacio
con una infraestructura diseñada para
poder cubrir sus necesidades y que al
igual buscamos ayudar a los animales en
situación vulnerable pero que ellos
mismos permitan complementar la misión
de la asociación que es generar
verdaderos cambios en el comportamiento
de nuestra sociedad en cómo se trata y
se ve a estos seres el proyecto del
santuario refleja de forma clara que los
animales por su mestizaje
o cualquier otra característica física
no son candidatos a una adopción fácil
se enfrentan a que la sociedad los sigue
rezagando y con esto pasen todo el resto
de su vida esperando un hogar y siendo
sujetos de forma directa a las
exigencias poco sustentadas para su
adopción pues es muy cierto que no
existirá refugio santuario o hogar que
permita albergar a millones de animales
que a diario nacen en la vía pública
viven en una situación precaria dentro
de un hogar o son sujetos a los peores
actos de crueldad pero qué bien este
proyecto invita de una forma muy real al
cambio de conductas de aquellos que
quieran detenerse a conocer que en
realidad es la que hoy viven la mayoría
de los animales tan solo 500 mil perros
y gatos son abandonados cada año y esa
cifra aumenta un 20 por ciento anual
según datos de la paot que es la
procuraduría ambiental y del
ordenamiento territorial
esto genera no sólo un caos y problemas
serios de salud en la sociedad sino que
también normal y cese actuar además no
olvidemos que en méxico no se cuenta con
entornos formalizados de educación o de
seguridad respecto a estos temas
sociales debido a que méxico no cuenta
con una vasta cultura de tenencia
responsable y si a esto se añade el nulo
interés por legislar sobre estos temas
se crea un entorno complejo en donde se
normalice y se propaga un actuar
negativo en contra de ellos por lo tanto
en forma sustancial no se aprecian
verdaderos cambios el maravilloso sueño
que me plantea en la adolescencia se
volvió un proyecto a trabajar ahora lo
vivo como una realidad en la que he
comprobado como si uno se aferra a sus
ideales y les dé lugar el tiempo y el
espacio necesarios tendrán resultados
que les sorprenderán desde muy joven
empecé a forjar mi sueño confiando en lo
que me impulsaba a actuar y confiando en
la intuición y durante todo ese proceso
desarrollé mi habilidad de observación
así es como he aprendido observando de
manera muy atenta llevar a cabo
proyectos no lucrativos que hacen
florecer las voluntades te pone en la
mira de todos esto es natural ya que
como humanos constantemente cuestionamos
todo lo que observamos y eso está bien
volverse un foco de atención por la
labor que uno desempeña hace que muchas
veces pueda llegar a sentirse un temor
por dicha atención pero a pesar de ese
sentimiento he aprendido que hay que
trabajar actuar con convicción
conviviendo con esos temores he
aprendido que hasta los proyectos más
inalcanzables aquellos que pensamos sólo
como sueños son posibles invitó a más
soñadores para que se sumen a buscar ya
descubrir qué es lo que mueve su
voluntad para que dirijan sus fuerzas a
soñar en grande en un periodo de 12 años
de trabajo constante me enfrentado a
todo tipo de situaciones y aunque muchos
han sido desagradables todas me han
regalado un toque de madurez y han
enriquecido mi sueño de alguna manera
porque creemos que es tan complicado
llevar a cabo los sueños a un plano real
en mi experiencia puedo decir que es
importante centrarse en observar
nuestras conductas en cómo vamos
haciendo las cosas en lugar de querer
obtener resultados de forma inmediata
esto marca el camino para ir
desarrollando un proyecto también he
observado tanto en mí como en otras
personas que la educación que recibimos
en la infancia es clave para definir el
rol que llevaremos a cabo como parte de
la sociedad la familia y las
interacciones que tenemos desde pequeños
son de suma importancia ya que influyen
en la manera en la que nos comportaremos
como adultos y porque pueden interferir
o por el contrario alentar la capacidad
que tendremos para hacer realidad un
sueño
en muchos hogares predomina el hábito de
hacer del miedo una herramienta de
aprendizaje y aunque muchas veces se
trate de un acto inconsciente ese
aprendizaje basado en el miedo saldrá a
relucir en el futuro de muchas maneras a
pesar de lo anterior
afortunadamente los seres humanos desde
muy pequeños aprendemos a observar ya
seleccionar lo que nos parece mejor
algunos somos muy afortunados de poder
desarrollar desde muy temprana edad las
acciones que nos habrán de caracterizar
el resto de nuestra vida
aquí quiero hacer énfasis en lo que
social y tradicionalmente se nos impone
como lo más importante
frecuentemente escuchamos que una
profesión es mejor que otra se nos
advierte lo importante que es elegir la
carrera mejor remunerada se nos habla de
lo que no deberíamos aspirar a hacer y
desde niños somos constantemente
bombardeados con ideas sobre las
aptitudes que deberíamos imitar para ser
exitosos pero con ello es muy probable
que estemos reprimiendo nuestras
aptitudes naturales
esas aptitudes que son el motor de los
sueños y de los proyectos y que de
seguirlas nos harían crecer siendo
humanos llenos de felicidad y plenitud
cuando somos jóvenes normalmente
carecemos de muchos miedos y tenemos un
auténtico interés por aprender cosas
nuevas durante la niñez tenemos
actitudes inocentes y creemos que todo
es posible imaginamos lo que podríamos
llegar a ser la más breve visita a un
museo a una fábrica oa un consultorio
médico pueden impactar favorablemente en
el resto de nuestra vida inspirarnos y
cambiar nuestra mente
porque dejamos de seguir nuestros
impulsos como cuando éramos niños
sabías que solamente el 8% de la
población mundial puede decir que ha
llegado a cumplir sus sueños este es un
dato recientemente publicado por la
revista foros aquellos que tienen la
fortuna de decir esto reportan que todo
fue gracias a que se escucharon a sí
mismos y no se dejaron llevar por sus
inseguridades que nos impiden concretar
los sueños los invito a reflexionar
piensen en algo que quisieron lograr
pero aparentemente no pudieron les
invito a pensar si lo que les detuvo fue
el miedo ignoraron su intuición cuáles
fueron sus temores tuvieron miedo a la
crítica tal vez no quisieron enfrentar
los posibles resultados hay que
reconocer que no hay de malo en tener
tales conductas y pensamientos como lo
mencioné antes yo aprendí a actuar a
pesar del miedo siempre observando y
actuando con convicción las cosas van
mal cuando dejamos que el miedo se
interponga ante todo impidiendo que
actúe nuestra propia intuición
considero eso como el peor de los
escenarios además de ser un error porque
no nos daríamos cuenta lo que es capaces
de lograr la mayoría de las personas no
se permiten tener sueños en la etapa
adulta porque se dejan llevar por las
imposiciones sociales y económicas en
ese sentido creo que tenemos un problema
grande como sociedad una gran mayoría de
los adultos con los que interactuamos
diariamente actúan por inercia pocos
serán la oportunidad de cuestionarse qué
es lo más importante para ellos que los
hace vibrar y que hace que surja su
voluntad
desafortunadamente vivimos en una
sociedad en donde una gran parte de la
población reprime sus sueños y muchas
veces no tienen o no se dan la
oportunidad de preguntarse qué es lo que
es más importante para ellos mientras
estas situaciones sigan predominando
vamos a seguir viviendo en un mundo de
falsos ideales sueños truncos ideas
olvidadas e ilusiones dormidas
qué es lo que me ha permitido concretar
este sueño y por ende seguir trabajando
en mi proyecto lo he creído al 100%
jamás he dudado de él debo decir que el
tiempo es un factor del que soy
consciente en mi día a día
naturalmente sé que esto no se detendrá
sin embargo nunca he dejado que el
tiempo determinen la manera en la que
vivo la constancia me ha hecho lograr
tener un ritmo para obtener ciertos
resultados si a esto le agregamos una
voluntad siempre encaminada a lograr mi
sueño el resultado es que gracias a ello
el rumbo que me ha marcado está claro al
igual que el compromiso que tengo con mi
proyecto
con todo lo que he dicho me gustaría
hacerte ver que el sueño que tienes en
mente el que estás viviendo ahora o el
que aún estás por vivir cuando le das el
espacio adecuado en tu vida solo puedes
perder tu alegría tu infinita
imaginación y tu valentía esto te
permitirá proyectar tus deseos más
profundos revelando tu verdadera
identidad y tu verdadera convicción como
soñador
hoy puedo decir con plena certeza y
absoluta seguridad que la experiencia y
el conocimiento adquiridos en este
camino me han mostrado y hecho entender
que los sueños no se cumplen los sueños
se sudan se lloran se trabajan y se
logran muchas gracias